TO GALLAGHER [inaudible]
SALAS [inaudible]
HAS [inaudible]
SINCE KALRA.
KILEY BEFORE HE TWO NORTH YES
RATES [inaudible]
AND RIGHT THANK YOU THIS IS THE
FIRST MEETING OF THE SOME OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE ON A WELCOME
OUR NEW MEMBER.
AND SALAS WHO'S ACTUALLY SERVE
WITH US QUITE OFTEN LAST YEAR
BUT IS NOW PERMITTED. TO NORRIS
WELCOME.
AND THE MISTER GALLAGHER WHO
DEIGN TO COME BACK. FOR US LAST
ACTUALLY SO.
WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM BACK WE
HAVE TWO ITEMS BEFORE US TODAY.
FIRST ADOPTION CAN BE RULES OF
THE COMMISSION I THANK YOU RULES
ARE ADOPTED OUR FIRST ITEM THAT
IS HR.
SIX SMOKE THANK YOU KAREN
MEMBERS.
AT THE SUPREME COURT PASSED
ALONG LANDMARK DECISION FORTY
SIX YEARS AGO SECURING A WOMAN'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO PRIVACY
INCLUDE HER RIGHT TO ABORTION.
ROE VERSUS WADE WAS A VICTORY
FOR WOMEN TO OWN THEIR OWN
BODIES.
AND LAY THE GROUNDWORK FOR
FURTHER REPRODUCTIVE AND SEXUAL
HEALTH CARE POLICIES THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY.
IN CALIFORNIA WHERE WHAT TO
STATES FOR THE RIGHT IS
PROTECTED BOTH IN STATUTE AND IN
OUR CONSTITUTION.
HOUSE RESOLUTION SIX SOLIDIFIES
THE ASSEMBLY SUPPORT AND
COMMITMENT TO PROTECT THAT
PERSON'S FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO
DECIDE IF AND WHEN THEY BECOME
APPARENT.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE MOTION AS
THEIR SECOND.
THE MOTION IS THAT THE
RESOLUTION BE ADOPTED.
AND THAT SO LET ME JUST FINISH
UP AND THEY DO IT HAVE SOME
FOLKS HERE IN THE ROOM --
TO SUPPORT THIS.
EVEN WITH THESE PROTECTIONS THE
RIGHT TO ACCESS A WORKING SAFELY
AND LEGALLY IN THIS COUNTRY IS
IN JEOPARDY AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO PREFER IT CAN
STILL MERRILEES FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT.
THE PROTECTIONS GRANTED THAT I
WROTE THIS IS RATE ARE AT THEIR
HIGHEST RATES AND BEING
OVERTURNED I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
ABOUT.
THANK YOU DO HAVE WITH THIS IS
IN SUPPORT.
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
I THINK THOSE ARE.
HAVE THIS IS WHAT WE COULD.
THIS IS THE ONE I GUESS.
YES THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING FOR
RIGHT NOW AS A MATTER OF FACT
[inaudible]
WHAT?
CAN YOU MAKE IT THREE TIMES
MORNING REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE MY HUSBAND WITH A GREAT
SCENARIO AND WHAT NAY EIGHTY
YEAH AND I'M MARRIED.
WOMEN COLOR FINDS THAT SHE'S
PREGNANT.
SHE IS TERRIFIED TERRIFIED OF
HOW HER PARENTS OVERSIGHT.
FIND OUT.
WHAT THIS MEANS FOR FOR
PROFESSIONAL AN EDUCATIONAL
PROCESS?
THIS YOUNG WOMAN WOULD GO ON TO
GIVE BIRTH MOM AND HER FRIENDS A
CERTAIN.
IN.
THE SUMMER OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE THIS HAVE BEEN HERE EIGHT
YEARS EIGHT THAT'S HAPPENING
HERE EIGHT YEARS LATER THIS
WOMAN.
WOULD HAVE BEEN A KIND HEARTED
UPDATE WORKING IN ST.
SHE TAKE ALL THE BOXES.
YOU MAY THINK I'M ABOUT TO GO ON
AND OUR HOW.
MY LIFE AND MY DAUGHTER'S LIKE
TO THE FACT THAT. FOR THE WAY
AND YOU SEE HOW MY MOTHER HER
THINGS INTO THE SEAT EIGHT YEARS
LATER.
IT'S MORE THAN LIKELY THAT BOTH
OF THEM WE'VE BEEN POISONED OR
VIOLENTLY RIGHT WHEN FROM LAND.
AND THEN SECTION DR YOUNG
MOTHERS WHEN.
THE WHAT IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT
ANOTHER TO SILENT VICTIMS IN
ONGOING AMERICAN PUBLIC OFFICE.
THIS MORNING YOU'LL LEARN ON A
RESOLUTION CELEBRATING THE
PASSENGER FOR THE WEIGHT.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I AND SO MANY
OTHERS LIVING COUNTER THIS ISSUE
ON A DAILY BASIS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS NOT
BUT THE IS WHAT THE INDUSTRY
CLAIMS IT TO BE.
MEANS OF WOMEN IN THIS RECIPE
JOIN PREGNANCY.
INTO.
AN EXISTENTIAL CRISIS.
SOME OTHER GUYS CHILD IT'S
HEALTH MOVING THAT THEY CANNOT
AND WILL NOT.
AMOUNT TO ANYTHING.
THAT THIS CURRENT CHALLENGE IS
INSURMOUNTABLE.
IN LIKE IT'S HUMAN BEINGS TO
ANIMATE COMES TO SELL EVEN A
SCIENTIFIC ADVANCES GIVE US A
CLEAR WINDOW.
INTO THE THE MOTHER'S WOMB TO
SEE HELLO MY NAME IS A GREAT
BERKELEY CA ALSO AND THEN WOULD
YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME.
SORRY MY EXACTLY WHEN THEY CAN
LIVE YEAH.
MY NAME IS A GREAT BURKE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL --
IN THE THE WORDS I SPEAKING
TODAY ACTUALLY FROM SOMEONE ELSE --
WHEN IT SPILLS THE DIRECTOR THE
CALIFORNIANS?
CALIFORNIA'S.
VOTES NEVER SHE'S BEEN HERE MANY
TIMES IN OPPOSITION OR TO COULD
BE HER DAY SHE'S ACTUALLY FROM
ABORTION CLINIC.
OFFERING HELP TO WOMEN AND SO.
BECAUSE BURKE ON ON HER BEHALF
AND SO THE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
WE CAN ALL PREDICT THE OUTCOME
OF THIS VOTE.
SOME WOULD SAY A WASTE OF TIME
EVEN SPEAK.
BUT THERE'S ALWAYS MERIT IN
SPEAKING TRUTH TO POWER.
YOU HAVE THE POWER AND WE ALL
KNOW THE TRUTH.
IN THE U. S. SIXTY MILLION LIVES
HAVE BEEN KILLED BY ABORTION
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE IN
SOME LIMóN FOR A LIFETIME
LEADING MANY TO SUFFER FROM
DEPRESSION ANXIETY.
PANIC ATTACKS NIGHTMARES.
DRUG AND ALCOHOL ADDICTION AND
THOUGHTS OF SUICIDE ESPECIALLY
FOR WOMEN WHO ARE LIKE TO BUY
THE ABORTION INDUSTRY TELLING
THEM THAT WAS A CLUMP OF CELLS
SOME TISSUE.
YEAH WE KNOW THE TRUTH.
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM HAS HEARD
THE HEARTBEAT OF A BABY WHICH
STARTS AT TWENTY ONE DAYS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE ULTRASOUND
IMAGES.
OF BABIES ARMS AND LEGS OF FACE
NO DOUBT IN THE THE CHARITY AND
I LOVE I HOPE THAT SOMEDAY EACH
OF YOU WILL HAVE A CHANGE OF
HEART.
JUST LIKE JANE ROE OF ROE VERSUS
WADE.
HER REAL NAME IS NORMA MCCORVEY.
WHO ACTUALLY NEVER HAD AN
ABORTION IN LATER LIFE HAD A
COMPLETE CHANGE OF HEART?
BECOMING A PRO LIFE LEADER --
LATER IN LIFE ALONG SIDE OF
FORMER ABORTIONIST IN NAY RALPH
FOUNDER DOCTOR BERNARD NATHANSON.
WHO PERFORMED OVER SIX SIXTY
THOUSAND ABORTIONS IN HIS
LIFETIME THE LABOR LATER WE CAN
YOUR CALL AFTER THIS?
THERE IS HOPE AND FORGIVENESS
EVERYONE OF US SEEKS GOD'S MERCY.
TO DATE THIS FIGHT THE POWERS
AROUND ME I WILL NOT BE SILENT
ABOUT THE MATTER OF ABORTION.
WHICH DOCTOR BERNARD NATHANSON
THE FOUNDER OF NAY RAVEL.
CALLED THE MOST THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME IS AND GIVE ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE I WILL --
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MAY I JUST
HAVE A GROWN MAN AND I'M REALLY
SORRY I SPENT MOST OF MY LIFE
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE.
ALSO HAVE OTHER ACCESS AND THEY
DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS.
AND I FIND THAT VERY SERIOUSLY.
BUT WITH ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS
ALSO TAKE SERIOUSLY TO YOU CALL
AN ABORTION INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE YOU TALK ABOUT --
BIRTH MOM TWO GENERATIONS AGO.
BUT MISSED GENERATION I WAS THE
YOUNG WOMAN OF COLOR WHO IS I'M
MARRIED AND WALKED INTO A
PLANNED PARENTHOOD WITH AN
UNEXPECTED PREGNANCY.
AND THAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD WHEN
I SAID I HAD NO DOUBT THAT HAVE
THAT CHILD.
OFFERED TO LET ME HEAR THE HEART
BEAT.
THAT'S NOT AN ABORTION INDUSTRY
THAT IS CARING INDIVIDUALS TO
ENSURE WORK THE SAFETY AND
PARENTHOOD HAVE FAMILY PLANNING
AVOID ABORTIONS AT ALL COSTS
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO
HAVE ABORTIONS I DON'T THINK
ANYONE WANTS PEOPLE TO HAVE A
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT.
ABORTION INDUSTRY TITLE EVEN
COMES FROM ITS OFFENSES IT'S
DEEPLY OFFENSIVE.
BECAUSE MY MOM IN THE SAME YEAR
SO YOUR TALK ABOUT YOUR MOTHER
WORKING EMERGENCY ROOM WHEN
BEFORE WE WENT.
AND THE STORY SHE TELLS ABOUT
YOUNG WOMEN WHO CAME IN WITH
POSH ABORTIONS THAT YOU'LL NOT
ONLY THE BIG THE BABY IS HIGHER
BUT THE GIRLS YOURSELF.
THOSE ARE MY SKILLS.
AND WHAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED IN
THE HIGH SEAS ESPECIALLY HOW
CALIFORNIA WILL READ VALUE THE
RIGHTS OF WOMEN TO TO HELPING
THE COMMUNITY IS THE APPOINTED
SUBJECT.
AND I THINK THAT'S A GOOD THING.
AND I THINK WE COULD WORK
TOGETHER IF WE GOT PASSED SOME
OF THE JUST REVIEWED RHETORIC
AND BIGGER OUT HOW WE CAN
SUPPORT YOUR MOM TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE HAVE CHILD ESPECIALLY
THOSE WERE UNSUPPORTED AND I
MERRY.
AND WE SO SELDOM GET THIS KIND
OF PASSION ABOUT THAT.
AND INSTEAD WORK TOGETHER TO
FIGURE OUT ALSO HOW WOMEN HAVE
ACCESS.
TO MANY INTEL UNEXPECTEDLY.
SO I I THINK YOU FOR FOR YOUR
HEARTFELT TESTIMONY BUT I ALSO
WANTED TO TO THANK THE PEOPLE
WHO CAME HERE COMPANIES.
BECAUSE ARE NOT AN OPTION
INDUSTRY.
CARING INDIVIDUALS WHO CARE FOR
WOMEN IN KEEP THEM IN STATE
POSITIONS OF MAKING PROGRAMS
RESOLUTION FLAT.
I WAS ABLE TO SECOND AT THIS IS
ALSO THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS WAS
GALLAGHER. FOR THE SAME THE ONE
ITEM ACTUALLY AGREEING THAT I
HAVE TALKED ABOUT YOU KNOW I
THINK WHEN YOU GET PASS PLANNING
OUR FLAGS ON EACH SIDE WHERE WE
DISAGREE AND I THINK THE
FUNDAMENTAL WHY THIS IS STILL AN
ISSUE.
IS WE NEVER RECONCILE THE RIGHTS
OF THE UNBORN CHILD --
NEON SO ALSO AS A HUSBAND WHO
WATCHES WIFE GO THROUGH THREE
HIGHWAYS FOR HIGH RISK
PREGNANCIES --
AND WAS THERE AT SEVENTEEN WEEKS
WHEN THEY'RE AT UCSF WHEN THEY
WERE DOING AN ECHO CARDIOGRAM ON
THEIR TEAMS.
MY TWINS TO BE HEARTS.
THERE CLEARLY IS SOMETHING HERE
THAT WE HAVE TO RECONCILE THAT
THERE.
THERE IS ANOTHER LIFE YOU'RE
ALSO THIS A WOMAN'S LIFE AND IS
ALSO.
AN UNBORN CHILD --
AND SO I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT I
WHERE I WANT TO SAY IS I THINK
LIKE INSTEAD OF US LIKE CONTINUE
TO PLANT FLAGS AND DO.
RESOLUTIONS --
LET'S HAVE A DISCUSSION HOW WE
CAN DO BETTER FOR BUT HOW CAN WE
DO BETTER FOR WOMEN IN A CRISIS
PREGNANCY.
AND HOW CAN WE RECOGNIZE THE
RIGHT SET OF OF THE ON BOARD --
IT SHOULD BE A CHOICE BETWEEN.
THOSE WHO ARE WANTED WE DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO SAVE.
YEAH YEAH SO I THINK THAT'S
ATTENTION AS WE CONTINUE.
TO WORK ON THIS ISSUE BUT IT'S
BETTER TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS I THINK.
YOU KNOW THAN --
AND WHAT YOU CAN SEE MAYBE ON
THE THE POLARIZING --
SO WITH THAT.
THANK YOU OTHER.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS ALRIGHT THANK
YOU THIS THE MYT FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD FROM MY STANDPOINT.
I THINK THAT.
WE DO IN FACT AND EVERY WOMAN I
HAVE TALKED TO WHO HAS
CONTEMPLATED ARE GONE THROUGH.
THIS ISSUE TAKES IT VERY
SERIOUSLY AND DOESN'T FACT
CONSIDER.
THE LIFE OF THE CHILD THAT SHE'S
CARING IT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
IT'S A VERY EMOTIONAL
[inaudible]
CIRCUMSTANCE [inaudible]
BUT FROM A WOMAN'S RIGHT TO
CHOOSE HER BODY.
HER ABILITY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
AND ALL WILL BE WEEK REALLY DOES
WHICH IS WHITE SO WORTH.
SUPPORTING IS PROVIDE THAT
OPTION.
OR A REAL OPTION WITHOUT
GOVERNMENT INTERVENTION THAT'S
WERE WE THE RATE.
THE WAY IT STANDS.
FOR BECAUSE IT IS A WOMAN'S.
CHOICE.
IN HER CIRCUMSTANCE TO DO WHAT
SHE FEELS IS BEST.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING FORWARD
WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE THE
SECOND TO THE MOTION IS THAT THE
H. R. SIX BE ADOPTED --
THIS LOAD THE CLOTHES.
I RESPECT.
ALL OF THE COMMENTS.
ON THAT HAVE BEEN MADE I I THINK
THAT THEY ARE IMPORTANT COMMENTS
AND PART OF THE DISCUSSION.
BUT CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW IN IN WHAT'S BEEN SAID
I ALSO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT SHOWS
WE STARTED TO SEE WOMEN.
GO TO BACK ALLEYS WE STARTED TO
HEAR ABOUT A HANGER MATHIS AND I
WASN'T CLEAR WITHOUT LESS.
SO THE REALITY IS.
THAT FOR SO MANY WOMEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THEY HAVE TO PURSUE OTHER
OPTIONS I HAVE YET TO DATE TO
MEET ANY WOMAN WHO SAYS IN MY
FACE WHO LOOKS ME IN THE EYES
WHO I KNOW OF THAT SAYS I WANT
AN ABORTION.
THIS IS A DIFFICULT DECISION.
AND ONE THAT THEY MAKE.
WITH DOCTORS.
WITH ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD.
AND I APPRECIATE WHAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ HAS SHARED
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD THAT OVER AND
OVER A WOMEN WHO DO WALK.
INTO CLINICS AND CENTERS AND SAY
I'VE GOT THE MOST OBJECTIVE
INFORMATION TO MAKE THAT
DECISION.
AND THE REASON FOR THIS
RESOLUTION.
IS NOT. TO OVER POLITICIZING
ISSUE IT IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT
WOMEN REMEMBER WE HAVE A RIGHT.
AND THIS IS A LONG FOUGHT RIGHT
TO MAKE THAT CHOICE.
DO YOU HAVE AN OPINION THAT IS
RESPECTED.
AND THAT IS YOUR CHOICE IS THE
MONEY YOU NEED TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE.
I ALSO THINK THAT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO RESPECT EVERYONE
AND ABILITY TO MAKE THIS CHOICE
HERSELF.
AND FOR THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I HAVE A THANK YOU.
STONE BY STONE AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
FIVE CHILD FIVE SHOWING.
TO YOU I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER KNOW GONZALEZ I
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HI KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO PEACHTREE NORRIS.
I WANTED AYE KALRA. FIVE THIS
KILEY.
THANK YOU WE ARE ADJOURNED